if you're an American conservative it
has been a huge weekend for music an
unknown Southern folk singer became the
most popular musician in the country for
railing against the liberal
establishment the vague ramaswamy
wrapped Eminem at the Iowa State Fair
and best music of all
Hunter Biden's business partner sang
like a canary to the point that now the
doj has appointed a special counsel
which on the bright side proves that
Republicans were right all along and on
the downside further protects Joe Biden
and the Democrats I'm Michael knowlesis
the Michael nolsha
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers good
ranchers which I had for lunch yesterday
I just grilled myself up a beautiful
delicious New York strip steak that was
so freaking good like everything else
from good ranchers get great made it a
secure price 30 bucks off your order
with code Knowles goodranchors.com use
code Knowles today
you remember that mother effer is not
real girl the one from the airplane
I'm sorry to say we now know who she is
I think probably there's a little
wrinkle to that we'll get into it and
I'm sorry to say she apologized
very sad
she had nothing to apologize for that
mother effer who was not real had a lot
to apologize for she did not we'll get
to that first though the big political
news
which every other news story is
distracting from but the actual
political news that affects your
political order is that uh the doj under
Merrick Garland Joe Biden's extremely
political
wheeling and dealing Attorney General
has just appointed a special counsel to
investigate Hunter Biden on Tuesday of
this week Mr Weiss advised me that in
his judgment his investigation had
reached a stage at which he could should
continue his work as a special counsel
and he asked to be so appointed
upon considering his request as well as
the extraordinary circumstances relating
to this matter I have concluded that it
is in the public interest to appoint him
as special counsel
this appointment confirms my commitment
to provide Mr Weiss all the resources he
requests
now you heard that
he didn't say we have appointed a new
special counsel to investigate Hunter
Biden he said Mr Weiss David Weiss who
is the U.S attorney who had been on the
hunter Biden case he has asked that he
have his title changed have his role
changed to continue the investigation
Weiss has been investigating Hunter
Biden for these investigations have been
going on for years
Weiss was involved in all of the
seemingly incompetent plotting dead end
BS Hunter Bud investigation that
culminated in the attempt by prosecutors
like David Weiss to get Hunter Biden a
plea deal that would have led him off
the hook for all of his crimes wouldn't
have even addressed the most serious
crimes would have given him a slap on
the wrist for tax crimes which were the
evidence of the deeper crimes the
political corruption and would have put
him in a diversion program for the gun
charge so that the the gun crime would
have been expunged from his record so
this is a guy a prosecutor who has every
step of the way tried to let the
criminal off the hook and now now that
the evidence is just so clear not only
of Hunter Biden's personal crime but of
the corruption that it means for the
Biden family now all of a sudden David
Weis has said well you know what I can't
continue this investigation at the doj
all of my schemes to try to let them
items off the hook have been foiled so
now I need to be an independent special
counsel
so that I can further screw up this
investigation on the one hand this is
nice news in that it shows the public
beyond a shadow of a doubt that the
hunter Biden investigation is serious
that Hunter Biden's crimes are serious
the whole time Democrats have said no he
didn't do anything wrong Republicans are
just distracting this is bsbsbs CNN ran
endless segments about how there was no
evidence against Hunter Biden much less
against Joe
the allegations without evidence mostly
that Republicans have out there there
has been no corroboration there's no
evidence there I mean you would agree we
don't have there's no evidence of that
at all Republicans get riled up and keep
making allegations that at this point
have not been substantiated with
evidence so far there is no evidence
that the evidence has come out they
don't have evidence
to show that Joe Biden did anything
wrong Commerce said that repeatedly he's
like well I hope we find evidence of
course they present that without clear
evidence so if there was evidence that
they had accumulated in their four to
five year investigation this request to
be a special counsel would have come
already it seems unlikely that that that
they have that kind of evidence so
before we move on to why this is
actually bad for republicans and a
pretty crafty move by Biden and the
Democrats just I don't want to gloss
over the fact that all of those people
were completely dead wrong every single
person you just heard the CNN anchors
the CNN guests the former prosecutors
the special legal analysts all just
completely wrong the Republicans write
the whole time your dumb hillbilly hick
Uncle Jimbo in the middle of the
mountain somewhere is it you know these
binds are corrupt that guy totally right
completely Vindicated has much better
legal Insight than all of the Geniuses
in the neckties on CNN
now probably what they were doing was
not just being ignorant and naive they
probably were doing what the corporate
media always do which is cover up for
the liberal establishment truth be
damned but they were wrong
by their own standards the appointment
of the special counsel proves that there
is a lot of evidence there is a there
there and they're going to investigate
it the reason this is bad though for the
conservatives is one
look who the special counsel is
the the guy who has bungled this
investigation and actively intentionally
tried to undermine the case against
Hunter Biden is now the guy in charge
as special counsel not just as U.S
attorney he's the last person in America
who should be in charge of it if you
actually wanted to get to the bottom of
something if you actually wanted to
punish Hunter Biden but of course they
don't
one of the reasons that they've
appointed uh the special counsel
is to give themselves a little bit of
distance
so they can pretend it's not true but
they can pretend that actually Merrick
Garland and Joe Biden they really don't
have anything to do with this now we
want to make sure there's no semblance
of impropriety the other reason they're
doing this is because it's going to make
it a lot easier for Weiss and his office
and the doj to resist Congressional
subpoenas now that the republicans in
Congress are finally digging into this
stuff now that Jim Jordan and the
Judiciary Committee and all of these
Republican investigators are
interviewing Devin Archer Hunter Biden's
former business partner are hearing
stories of Joe Biden's significant
involvement in all of these crooked
business deals now that that evidence is
coming out the doj comes in and whether
this will be successful or not is at
least trying to throw a roadblock up
there to stop the Republicans from being
able to talk to the people who
intentionally screwed up that
investigation they're they're just going
to Stonewall and Stonewall and Stonewall
the election is only a year and a half
less than a year and a half away now the
2024 election so they're just going to
try to drag this thing out until nobody
cares anymore of course at least though
we can take the tiny Victory we were
right
we were right the whole time and being
right proving that there's a double
standard is not going to do anything
that in a buck 50 will get Republicans a
cup of coffee but it is a reminder I
think the next time that the Democrats
try to throw some BS legal argument at
us that you know some Midwestern granny
is a terrorist and needs to be thrown in
solitary confinement that Donald Trump
because he gave a speech is an
insurrectionist at a threat to democracy
and can't be on the ballot whatever BS
they throw at us that sometimes
convinces the libs and the squishes and
the center-right people who want to get
along this should be a reminder the
whole thing is completely fixed the
whole thing is completely rigged we are
not playing by the same set of rules
here and if we try if we lie down in the
name of principles or something we are
we are
conceding the country
unjustly to people who have absolutely
no respect for the rule of law
whatsoever and that's not very good and
that's going to screw up all sorts of
things our system of justice our economy
and when both of those things are wonky
you're going to want to check out Birch
gold right now text Knowles to 98 98.98
as central banks and countries like
China India and Australia begin
transitioning to a digital currency the
Federal Reserve has been contemplating
the same for the U.S with the digital
currency the government could track
every single purchase you make officials
could even prohibit you from purchasing
certain products or easily freeze or
seize part or all of your money these
are some of the reasons that concerned
Americans have reached out to Birch gold
they want to have a physical asset like
gold that is independent of the US
dollar you can protect your IRA or 401K
by diversifying with gold from Birch
gold historically gold has been a safe
haven in times of high uncertainty which
is right now learn if gold is right for
you too text Knowles can wlas to 98 9898
they will send you a free info kit on
gold with an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews I trust Birch gold to help you
diversify into gold if a central bank's
digital currency becomes a reality it'll
be nice to have some gold to depend upon
right now text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98
speaking of incompetence at the FBI the
FBI executed a five foot six three
hundred pound 75 year old
practical invalid over the weekend this
is a really really sad story there's a
guy in Utah I guess the news broke
sometime on Friday 75 year old man
who had posted some threats to against
Joe Biden on his personal Facebook page
that had very few connections was
executed by the FBI how did it happen
well
there was a SWAT team that showed up
there were agents who showed up there
were gunshots the the video that the
only video that we really have of it
shows a massive show of force very very
early in the morning against this guy
and what the FBI is saying is that well
he was resisting and so they had to take
him out they left his body out just
bloodied covered with just a bloody
sheet for a long time why did they do it
because he did post threats he said I'm
going to go out here when Joe Biden
comes to town I'm going to bring my gun
out I'm gonna show up there I'm going to
put a bullet in his head he was saying
all sorts of terrible things
did the FBI really believe this guy was
a threat
well maybe they didn't know that he was
so overweight maybe they didn't know
that he was so elderly maybe they didn't
know that he had trouble walking if you
talk to his neighbors his neighbors say
the guy could barely walk around he
barely went anywhere he was involved in
his church but that was pretty much it
he'd go from his house to his church and
he could barely walk the distance from
his car into the church so did the FBI
just not know that no the FBI did know
that because the FBI had actually had
two encounters with this guy
so they knew exactly what he was like
why didn't the FBI just pick him up when
he was getting out of his car walking
maybe to the grocery store or walking
maybe to church or why the FBI had been
surveilling this guy for months if they
thought that he was really a threat to
Joe Biden why didn't they arrest him
when there would have been less of a
chance for a violent confrontation the
only conclusion that I can draw is
either the FBI is just absolutely
completely incompetent
to a degree not just what we joke about
government incompetence all those
government bureaucrats they know what
they're doing I mean like doesn't know
the first thing about law enforcement or
this was a political decision to go in
there and show those damn right-wingers
what for make an example out of this 300
pound short guy who was 75 years old who
could barely move
I take
threats very seriously I'm not
dismissing the fact that this guy posted
on his Facebook page threats against the
president if somebody who has received a
threat or two before I'm always uh very
happy when law enforcement takes those
threats seriously the problem is law
enforcement very rarely takes those
threats seriously when they're against
conservatives
when prominent conservatives
get death threats I won't even name
names I won't even name examples because
frankly when you get too specific on
some of these examples they can put
people at even greater risk but
I've been around it enough to know very
often law enforcement won't do a damn
thing and everybody knows at the public
level law enforcement will get the most
Pro the most prominent criminals off the
hook
BLM burns the country down for eight
months they get off with a little slap
on the wrist
the midwestern granny shows up to the
Capitol rotunda they throw her in
solitary and they don't let her out
and that's exactly what's going on here
as far as I'm concerned unless some
shocking new evidence comes out
I just don't see how anybody
could conclude that this would be the
best way to pick this guy up the guy was
so immobile
that even if he had actually been
planning to go on the day that Joe Biden
showed up to Utah
Drive the 40 minutes to go to where Joe
Biden was get out and try to shoot him
or something the FBI could have probably
walked alongside him and picked him up
there was so much time they were
obviously watching him the whole time
did they really have to go in and kill
him
no
it's not that's not even the safest way
to pick him up
because if they're saying that this
actually was a violent dangerous
standoff then the agents were in far
greater trouble trying to arrest him at
his house they could have just picked
him up walking from his car
they didn't do it though I don't want a
Monday Morning Quarterback this thing
but when when the FBI gets caught spying
on Catholic churches because they think
that Catholics are a grave Terror threat
to America lying about spying on
Catholic churches getting caught lying
about spying on Catholic churches they
once said it was a single field office
turns out it was a nationwide program
involving multiple field offices when
the FBI shows up to fathers of seven
pro-life Advocates and and arrests them
in front of their kids and traumatizes
them for opposing abortion meanwhile
they celebrate The infanticidal Maniacs
give them prizes give them give them
special days and parades and
celebrations
you know something's very very corrupt
when the FBI spies on the Donald Trump
campaign because the Donald Trump
campaign is advocating for popular
conservative messages
meanwhile the FBI is coordinating with
the Clinton campaign and the Democrats
that's evidence of real corruption when
the FBI not just the FBI in this case
when the doj at the higher level goes in
and systematically
consistently tries to let Hunter Biden
and Joe Biden that's what they're really
protecting here when they let the bidens
off the hook for flagrant crimes that
we've seen with our own eyes the
messages the pictures the videos all of
it
and then doubles down when they get
caught and they say okay we're gonna put
in the special counsel investigation
over here and and don't worry nothing to
see Move Along Move Along nothing to see
here then when the FBI goes in and
executes some elderly obese man in Utah
who
according to all of his neighbors and
according to Common Sense didn't pose an
actual threat to anyone he was mouthing
off on Facebook I'm not excusing threats
but if you're using Prudence which is
the which is the highest political
virtue you recognize this guy didn't
pose a threat to anybody
I don't know what conclusion I can draw
other than yet again the FBI and the
Biden Administration and the liberal
establishment wanted to make an example
and let every conservative know in this
country you better keep your mouth shut
you bet forget about the Democrats who
get to go out in maraud and rape and
kill and murder they'll they get to do
whatever they want if you so much as
mouth off on Facebook we're going to
come to your home you could be elderly
you could be out of shape you could be
in terrible Health we will execute you
we'll leave you out for people to see
that to to learn from that example
really really
sad and unnecessary stuff this is
happening all around the world though
I've mentioned that the phenomenon of
conservative populism which we'll get to
in a second the biggest trending news
story of the whole weekend was this this
folk singer who came out of nowhere with
this Creed occur about how corrupt our
political order is
this happening all over the world
said the the anti-trump people in
America on the right and the left
they think that Trump is just a weirdo
and he's kind of funny and he's a
Carnival Barker and he's tricked people
into supporting him they don't recognize
that
the reason that he got so much support
is not just because he has a funny
personality but because he was
advocating a different political Vision
than the Republicans had been advocating
for the entirety of my lifetime he came
out and he questioned GOP Orthodoxy on
trade not just the squishes on trade but
even the so-called movement
conservatives he questioned GOP policies
on immigration not just the squishes but
the movement conservatives on and on and
on he was on couth and so they supported
him in the same way that the Brit
supported brexit in the same way that
the Italian supported Maloney in the
same way that the hungarians support
Victoria bond in the same way that the
Spaniards support the Vox party and in
Germany right now there's a far-right
political party called alternative for
Deutschland the afd
which is gaining support according to
latest polls the alternative for Germany
alternative for Deutschland has 21 in
the polls and don't forget this is a
system where there are lots of different
parties so that's a pretty significant
number and now the German president
Franz Franz Volta steinmeier warned in a
speech that they might just ban the
party
to save democracy to save democracy in
Germany
the president of Germany is considering
Banning outlawing
one of the most popular parties and the
party that in terms of political
momentum probably is the single most
popular
if you look at the direction of support
democracy to save democracy
the Liberals in America want to do the
same thing they want to throw the leader
of the opposition into prison
the president of the United States is
trying to imprison the leader of the
opposition
to do the American version of the exact
same thing they're trying to do in
Germany
and Germany has a history of banning
political parties America doesn't really
have that history so much but they're
going to do that because why because
the people the democracy is rejecting
liberalism
the the alternative for Deutschland do
you know they're real crime it's not
that they they're racist they're sexist
they're this is they're that is whatever
whatever the Liberals say
the afd came out and said the European
Union's a failed project
they're arguing for a Federation of
European nations and New Economic and
interest Community for Europe that
preserves the sovereignty of member
states that's the threat they're
threatening the the liberal hegemony
there and
even if all the people want to do that
even if the full democracy is saying we
reject liberalism the Liberals are going
to come in and in the name of democracy
say we've got to stop the people from
getting what they want
you know what I want sometimes when I'm
having a barbecue I want a nice tank of
propane and I don't want to be caught
without one which is why you got to
check out cinch right now go to
cinch.com use promo code Knowles picture
the perfect Summer Night the warm breeze
lapping your face as you Lounge in your
favorite chair outside the grill is
sizzling with Juicy
hot burgers the aroma of the food is
irresistible
and now imagine what that perfect summer
night would look like
if you went to turn on the grill in your
propane tank were empty
huh that's where our friends at cinch
come in cinch is a propane grill tank
Home Delivery Service they deliver
propane grill tanks right to your door
cinch delivers on your schedule requires
no long-term commitment or subscription
delivery is totally contactless you do
not have to wait around at home track
the order from the Cinch app anywhere
whether you are grilling steaks or
lighting up patio heaters on a cold
night cinches propane delivery service
ensures that you have the fuel that you
need to make the most of every moment go
to cinch.com or download the Cinch
c-ynch app to order new customers get
their first tank exchange for just 10
bucks with promo code Knowles cinch.com
or download the Cinch app use promo code
notes for your first tank exchange for
just 10 bucks limited time offer you
must live with an essential service area
to redeem it cinch.com offer for details
all around the West the people are
recognizing that the problem is not just
the Democrats the Liberals though
everywhere in other than one country
other than in Hungary which is a little
advanced in terms of the conservative
populist Uprising in every other country
in the West
people are realizing that the problem is
not just the liberal party which is the
dominant political party
throughout the whole civilization and
the problem is not just the conservative
political party which is the junior
partner in the liberal project but that
maybe the problem is the whole system
maybe this whole system that we called a
uniparty here in America
or the liberal establishment or whatever
that the
semblance of political opposition the
semblance of the representation of
diverse voices that in fact
castigates a large part if not the
majority of the people as deplorable
irredeemable not worth hearing they
should just go off and die somewhere let
small town America die let these tell
these people to learn to code tell them
to shut up they're insurrectionists they
need to be put in prison they need to be
banned on social media
the people are recognizing that system
might be the problem which is why
a man that nobody had heard of until
three days ago Oliver Anthony just went
viral and now has the number one song in
America top of the charts in the country
the song is called the rich man north of
Richmond this song is such a phenomenon
we have we have to play at least a good
chunk of it on the show because
what's most interesting about this
phenomenon is not the song everybody's
saying oh this is the greatest song in
recent memory and this guy's a musical
genius and
the story is
is more politically interesting than
just that take it away
I've been selling myself
over time hours for both pains so I can
sit out here and waste my life away
drive back home and down my troubles
are damn shame what the world's gotten
too for people like me people like you
wish I could just wake up and not be
true but it is
all it is living in the new world
Soul
these rich men North the Richmond Lord
knows that all just wanna have total
control
so the first thing that strikes me this
guy is a genuine musical Talent his
voice is is
captivating
he reminds me of Levon Helm
Levon Helm who is the drummer in the
bands you know bold into Nazareth was
feeling about he's got this this way of
wailing while he sings that is
sounds raw it sounds authentic it's
a little dangerous it's not this is not
a classically trained singer obviously
he's really good and his pitch is good
and he's playing a dobro guitar and the
whole thing just even looks a little bit
like Levon Helm he's got that red beard
and he's he's singing a song
about how he's selling his soul he feels
like he's losing his soul and he's
working for basically no pay and he's
drinking his troubles away and
the other thing that's that's raw about
this song is that
don't I'm not knocking the guy at all I
think this is a wonderful story and it's
a good song and but the the lyrics could
be tuned up you know he's rhyming away
with a way he's rhyming rich rich men
and rich men which is not those don't
actually rhyme the the lyrics are a
little bit confused here because is this
a is this a neo-confederate Anthem as
the Liberals are calling it Richmond is
the capital of the Confederacy so is
that what he's talking about those damn
Northerners coming in here and bringing
their reconstruction or something he's
wailing about this 200 years later 150
years later no I don't think so I think
he's probably referring to Washington DC
as the rich man north of Richmond and
they want to have total control
so they want to have total control but
is the problem that he's
that he's not making his money is the
problem that he is being forced to sell
his soul or being encouraged to sell his
soul is it is it a a substance question
the substantive nature of the political
order or is it a procedural aspect just
that these men want Total Control but we
don't want them to have control we're
not saying how people should live but we
are saying that those guys north of
Richmond shouldn't do it it's it's a
little bit confused so I don't think
that what is making this song go viral
is necessarily the lyrical content of it
you'll see why in just a second keep
going
[Music]
put a pause there this is
lyrically what's interesting to me too
is
you hear some real populist complaints
I'm selling I'm selling my soul
I'm not this is this is not the sort of
thing that Mitt Romney would complain
about there's another sort of thing John
McCain would complain about oh yeah this
new liberal economy is making us sell
our souls no and the we're not making
enough money
okay that's a populist complaint and
inflation is really bad the dollar ain't
worth that's a populist complaint
and it's taxed to no end
that
high taxes is not exactly a populist
complaint that's more of a an
establishment Paul Ryan Mitt Romney John
McCain kind of complaint and the fact is
virtually all the taxes in America are
paid by the rich anyway so it's it is
the rich men in Richmond well maybe not
them because they're corrupt government
apparatics in Washington D.C but it is
the wealthy generally who are paying
virtually all of the taxes in America so
that that's a little bit of a just
standard GOP complaint you know and
but the rest is populist and the whole
the whole vibe of the song is
this calling out literally calling out
from the woods in the middle of nowhere
keep going
I wish politicians look out for minors
and not just minors on an island
somewhere or once we've got folks in the
street ain't got nothing to eat and the
whole base milk and Wildfire put a pause
there so this is probably intentional to
to
be a contradiction or to maybe to seem
like a paradox but I don't think it is a
paradox I think it's just a
contradiction he's saying people in the
street don't have any food but but the
obese are milking welfare
people don't really go hungry in America
the the knock on the American political
order is that the poor robs and they're
not just obese because they're milking
welfare you could complain about welfare
again that's not
totally a populist complaint that's a
little bit more of the Mitt Romney Paul
Ryan kind of stuff and people don't
really starve the problem is that the
poor in America are obese because
because of the culture problems because
we've we've sold our political Soul
because we don't have
really Community or political love
anymore because marriages have fallen
apart because we've got rampant drug
abuse and addiction because we've got
people who are despondent don't think
they have a future because their money's
not worth anything and they can't get
any good jobs and so it's
it's all kind of jumbled up
it's a it's a stew of lamenting about
the political order
keep going we got a little bit more of
the song God if you're five foot three
and you're 300
six feet in the ground cause all this
damn country does is keep on kicking
them down
lord it's a damn shame what the world's
gotten to
be true but it is
all it is so this is this is where the
song really sings this is where the song
really takes off when you say when
you're five foot two and you're 300
pounds then welfare shouldn't be paying
for your box of fudge rounds it's so
unfair because you got ordinary men who
are being responsible who are trying to
take care of themselves and they're
putting themselves six feet in the
ground because they're dying deaths of
Despair and it's a damn shame because no
one's looking out for people like me and
people like you
backbone of America no one's looking out
for us and it's a damn shame and I wish
it weren't this way but it is and that
that's where it really sings because
it's not this happy-go-lucky BS Beltway
establishment
astro turf conservative movement which
says everything's really great we've got
iPhones and cheap Chinese products we
need to stop complaining and recognize
what a special wonderful political order
this is you say no there are really
structural problems and maybe we do have
cheap crap from China and maybe in a GDP
has been ticking up but life expectancy
is going down so clearly something's
rotten here that's a a beautiful
complaint and he's saying and it's a
damn shame and it shouldn't be this way
but it is but it is
very different from the
bubble gum
appeal to the Southern Man movement
conservative kind of music this is not
your average country song
okay very different the political
analogy would be in 2016 you've got a
you've got a bunch of GOP candidates and
they all have the same roughly the same
kinds of complaints this immigration
illegal immigration is out of control
they never complain about legal
immigration which is the Lion's Share of
immigration they say this illegal
immigration is out of control and
there's some economic problems but look
we're still the greatest most prosperous
most wonderful country on Earth and it's
always we don't have any real problems
and everything here is great but we just
got to work around the edges a little
bit we got some problems to fix and then
Trump comes in he goes nah man this is
all going a Hell in a hand basket this
is completely screwed up we are we are
going to become one of those whole
countries pretty soon if we keep it up
and we're we've got chaos and
destruction in our streets and I'm going
to turn it around and make America great
again and what all the chattering
consultant Geniuses at the time said was
this is too dark
oh this is too dark
and divisive what was the title of
Trump's campaign book every other
campaign book is standing up for
standing
the courage to stand in freedom and
liberty and happiness and freedom and
courage in the future and the Sunshine
by Senator so-and-so running for some
office or whatever and then Trump's book
was crippled America
and this song is this this is the anthem
of crippled America
this is not your usual we're gonna put a
boot up your derriere because this is
America and we bleed red white and blue
all day I mean there's a place for those
songs this isn't those songs this isn't
even a country song this is a folk song
and for the people who are criticizing
this guy and saying well he just
shouldn't be political
he is coming out of a very long line of
American folk music
he shouldn't be political you know we
should just get back to the old days of
Folk Music like Woody Guthrie and Pete
Seeger and Bob Dylan and Bruce
Springsteen for that matter and Joni
Mitchell and all these all these people
Joan Baez
[Music]
they're always political songs and
they're always fairly urgent
contemporary political songs
the reason that this is so fascinating
that he took off is
he's the first one of them to be
conservative
Woody Guthrie communist Pete Seeger
communist Bob Dylan was a big lip he's
oddly kind of conservative and more so
over the years but he's considered a big
lip he's the people who really love Bob
Dylan tend to be hippies Joni Mitchell
Neil Young Joan Baez Arlo Guthrie all
that all the popular folk singers in
America actually Arlo Guthrie got a
little bit conservative too though he
kind of there he kind of went back to
being a liberal they're all big Libs
and the fact that you've now got a guy
playing it this could be a Woody Guthrie
song
but he's a conservative what that tells
you is
truly
for the first time in my life
conservatism is the popular
counterculture
liberalism is not only the political
establishment as it has been for a long
time but now everybody knows it
this is the the Woody Guthrie's of today
are that guy
and that means that the the political
playbook for conservatives
has got to change and finally
we can start uh we can stop telling
ourselves these fairy tales that we have
for 50 years oh we're the real cool kids
we're the we finally are the real cool
kids the evidence is this kind of a song
the fact that when conservative movies
do squeak through they do extremely well
the fact that when conservative
politicians do squeak through they tend
to do extremely well and they pose such
a threat to the liberal political order
that the liberal political order starts
changing all of the election rules right
before the elections starts rigging the
elections and starts trying to throw the
candidates into prison not just here in
America they're obviously doing that but
around the entire West that is an
Insurgent culture that shows that the
people
after a long enough time have finally
woken up are you planning to send your
kid off to college this year
condolences now I've been on a lot of
college campuses go to at least I don't
know a dozen sometimes maybe upwards of
20 per year I've seen firsthand how
liberal ideology has infiltrated and
polluted these universities give your
kids a Fighting Chance by sending them
off with Jeremy's razors right now get
up to twenty to zero percent off select
razor and men's care bundles
like the shampoo body wash and
conditioner all paraben free sulfate
free woke free made here in the USA get
your son a Precision 5 razor with welded
steel blades and flipback trimmer that
will groom his face not his world view
help your son Escape academia's leftist
indoctrination by more than just a close
shave
go to jeremy'srazers.com for major deals
give Jeremy's back to college bundles a
full ride today my favorite comment
yesterday is from or on Friday rather is
from carsonian the great four six seven
two it says Michael if there was a
movement to reinstitute the kingdom of
the two sicilies today would you support
it I certainly would if I was given at
least one of the sicilies if I could be
the Archduke Grand VI count of one and I
don't even care which Sicily then it has
my full support speaking of
conservatives making music
you know I really like Vivek ramaswamy
he's a pal of mine we go back to college
together I think he's one of the most
exciting candidates in the GOP race I I
like a lot of what he's saying and
calling for and the way he's shaking it
up I
I have to formally disavow my friend
Vivek I have to because
I I have a line okay my line it's not
how you feel about immigration my line
is not how you feel about tariffs or
something my line is
if you Embrace hip-hop
if you Embrace I can't I just can't
I can't bring myself to accept that and
Vivek did Embrace hip-hop he wasn't he
could have gotten on the stage at the
Iowa State Fair and started humming
along to the Brandenburg concertos he
could have gotten there
and pulled out of kazoo and started
humming Fur Elise but he didn't
he
wrapped Eminem
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a pretty convincing rendition I'm
not the I'm not the biggest Eminem fan
in the world so I don't know how it's
supposed to sound but
I I am impressed and horrified that
Vivek knows all of the words
and I am dismayed that the audience
appeared to like it so I just formally
for once and for all
this about my friend
it's very Charming it is very if I can
take my own prejudices out of it
it is very Charming to see a candidate
get up there and do that and even if you
don't like Eminem and even if you think
that's it's a little too performative or
something like that
this is why this guy is rising in the
polls is because he is taking risks all
the time all sorts of risks he's risking
his money on the campaign I think he
made a like a
an eight-figure donation to his own
political campaign
he is going out there taking unpopular
stances sometimes so then they become
popular stances he's debating uh
abortion Advocates on the campaign Trail
he's getting in the scrum everywhere he
he's going giving speeches and support
of uh Trump even though he's sometimes
going after Trump and distinguishing
himself from Trump he's supporting Trump
on the indictment stuff but then he'll
go after him and he'll go after other
candidates and he's just mixing it up
man
and the only way that you even have a
chance of becoming the GOP nominee in
2024 is if you take risks
and the other candidates are not doing
that
the the also Rands who were at single
digits right now
they're obviously not taking risks and
even Governor DeSantis who's who is in
the best position to take Trump out
I don't blame him as the candidate so
much as I blame the campaign
they're not taking the risks that they
need and maybe that's on the candidate
too and sure the buck stops at the
candidate they've got to start taking
I'm not saying Rhonda Sanders needs to
get up and rap Eminem please don't wrap
Eminem nobody in America should rep
Eminem but
the other GOP candidates could learn
from Vivek right now
it is not possible to win this race in a
safe way
you're either going to You're Gonna Take
a big risk and it's either going to pay
off and you're going to jump from number
seven in the race to number three or
maybe even number two
or you're going to flame out that's a
big risk it had that gone a different
way had he messed up the words a little
bit or had someone heckled him he would
have looked completely humiliated it
actually would have hurt but he took the
risk and more importantly they're taking
risks on policy and they're taking risks
on places they're going to visit
meanwhile Trump shows up to the Iowa
fair and is warmly welcomed by the crowd
there was a clip that was going viral
there people seem to love him
four more years four more years you see
it now the the anti-trump people will
say well they weren't all there for
Trump and some people were there for
other candidates but
doesn't really matter guys because
every single poll
with the exception of Reuters every
single presidential poll right now has
shows the majority of Republicans
supporting Trump greater than 50 percent
and Reuters is a thing at 47 percent
and so I people sometimes accuse me of
flacking for
for
uh Trump I'm really not I'm really not
guys I'm describing the state of the
race right now
and
objectively describing the state of the
race might sound like flacking for Trump
because he is completely dominating the
race and the momentum is with him
so I don't I don't think that if you
want to if you support another candidate
you want to win this race don't shoot
the messenger man you've got to ask
yourself why is Trump dominating this I
feel that most of my take on on the 2024
has been hey Donald Trump is absolutely
crushing right now here's why I think
he's doing that and then the supporters
mostly of DeSantis but of other
candidates too will say well he
shouldn't be dominating I'll say yeah
maybe maybe I don't know whatever but he
is so here's why I think it stops saying
that he's dominating no he guys he just
is that is just a fact and if you want
to have even a snowball's chance in hell
at taking Trump out
then you need to at least begin to
understand why it is that he still has
support instead of just sneering at that
support and sneering at his supporters
that's what the GOP candidates all the
other candidates did in 2016
. that's what Hillary Clinton did in
2016. people still don't quite
get it now I've got a little tease for
you okay
And The Tease is
that that
mother effort isn't real girl has just
come out she's she's said who she is
she's issued an apology I know look I
teased it at the top of the show today
this is going to be an extended tease
because we're gonna have to get to this
tomorrow I'm sorry
we have to
there's no there's no more time we've
got to get to the member block right now
okay the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it become a
member use code knowleskin Wally asset
check out for two months free on all
annual plans
[Music]
oh